la mort tragique d'une cycliste de 33
ans hier sous un viaduc de la rue saint
denis
ça nous rappelle à quel point se
déplacer à bicyclette peut représenter
un risque à montréal nous vous avions
d'ailleurs demandé des endroits que vous
jugés dangereux
vous avez été très très nombreux à nous
répondre
reportage jean-sébastien cloutier une
cycliste qui dépose une fleur sainte de
la tristesse qui a frappé toute la ville
lundi matin c'est ici rue saint denis
qui est morte matile de blaye 33 ans une
orthophoniste de la csdm qui a été
écrasé par un camion alors qu'il allait
travailler en vélo juste à côté ce
graffiti cycliste resté en vie évitez
les viaducs les évitent jachet de
prendre deux trois messes
c'est interdit et doit donc l'idéal
c'est des bars qui marchaient sur le
trottoir
sinon je trouve ça vraiment dangereux ya
pas l'espace santé anti viatique pour
circuler le viaduc où est survenu
l'accident fait partie d'une série de
viaducs sous la ligne de chemin de fer
du canadien pacifique qui sépare le
plateau-mont-royal de heureusement parmi
les plus dangereux est achalandé de
montréal d'un plateau mont royal 10% des
déplacements sont faits avait longtemps
à rosemont petite patrie tout ça c'est
plus de 5%
c'est donc beaucoup de cyclistes dans ce
coin ci et ils convergent vers le centre
ville
suzanne lareau nous a montré les viaducs
qu'elle craignait le plus à commencer
par le long tunnel sur papineau entre
saint grégoire et heureusement c'est une
artère d'encagnane âge ça roule très
vite qui me choque le plus dans cette
infrastructure le sait que les trottoirs
est très large
donc ce serait pas celle de proposer aux
cyclistes d'emprunter le trottoir puis
celui à l'intersection saint joseph et
d'iberville surnommé tunnel de la mort
on n'est même pas à l'aise de marcher
sur le trottoir tellement que c'était 3
les voitures nous colle et s'est très
vite c'est très étroit pour les prévenus
vraiment appris dans un tunnel autres
lieux à risque le tunnel sous le viaduc
de la rue vendront aux déçus du
boulevard saint laurent un des plus
utilisés à montréal on ya déjà compté
1500 vélo par jour qui préférait y
rouler sur le trottoir
cet été la ville va complètement
réaménager les lieux
il y aura une piste cyclable à l'est les
voitures rouleront de l'autre côté on
sait bien qu'on peut pas aménager une
piste cyclable avec une bordure de béton
dans tous les viaducs c'est pas ça qui
manque
mais grattoir partager piétons cyclistes
dans l'esclave quand la largeur de la
chaussée terme et c'est même pas une
question se pose et la slack sécurité
est une priorité
et puis la cohabitation est nécessaire
de barredo comme mesure temporaire
l'arrondissement rosemont-petite-patrie
tracera pour vendredi des lignes
blanches sur les trottoirs sous ces
viaducs pour séparer vélos et piétons
en plus d'installer une signalisation
adéquate rouler sur ces trottoirs
deviendrait et si légal jean-sébastien
je le disais on a lancé un appel et
d'ailleurs je remercie les
téléspectateurs vous avez été très
nombreux sur notre courrier courriel
électronique d'autres adresses sur
twitter également pour nous donner des
pistes et vous en avez vu quelques-uns
de ces endroits
oui en plus des viaducs convient de
mentionner dans le reportage ya eu
d'autres vies a dit notamment le viaduc
rockland là entre outremont et ville
mont royal ainsi que l'intersection qui
suit juste à côté l'entrechat maroc
l'inde et avenue beaumont intersection
très dangereux ça nous a été signalé la
voie de service de décarie le long de
l'autoroute décarie évidemment boulevard
décarie la voie de service beaucoup de
voitures beaucoup de feux de circulation
un cycliste ne digère pas le choix de
rester sur le trottoir un autre nous a
écrit que les environs du métro vendons
tous les environs du métro vendôme était
un véritable guet-apens pour cyclistes
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de piétons
qui sortait beaucoup de va-et-vient
beaucoup d'autobus et plusieurs
intersections à risque entre autres sur
le plateau mont-royal avenue du parc et
avenue mont-royal on pourrait continuer
comme ça patrice pendant plusieurs
minutes un mot avant de se quitter
cyclistes qui contestait une
contravention parce qu'il avait roulé
sur le trottoir dans un viaduc justement
hors décision aujourd'hui
oui michel harvey avait pris la décision
de rouler sur le trottoir au lieu de
rouler sur l'avenue de lorimier sous le
viaduc masson et dit qu'il pleuvait ce
jour là qu'ils avaient des nids-de-poule
c'était très dangereux il avait
intercepté par la police avait une
amende il plaide donc la nécessité de
rester en sécurité s'attendait qu'à
cause du contexte actuel notamment ben
ils obtiennent gain de cause
ça n'a pas été fait devant la cour
municipale un juge a réduit son amende à
29 dollars mais il a donc perdu cinq ans
je laisse écouter
le juge me dit que je devais marcher à
côté de mon vélo quand j'étais sur notre
toit mais le code de sécurité routière
ne l'indiquent pas ne dis pas que
j'étais obligé de marcher il dit tout
simplement que je peux utiliser la voie
en cas de nécessité
si ce qui était mon corps bon très bien
en terminant vous dire patrice que ici
il y aura un événement souvenir pour
mathilde de blé lundi prochain il ya une
page facebook a été créée ça s'appellera
vélo fantôme
pour mathilde merci à jean sébastien je
remercie aussi les téléspectateurs
encore une fois avoir collaboré merci au
revoir
au revoir